cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret de la ville de
les clayes-sous-bois nous avons la
sortie nationale de spider man far from
home
nous vous conseillons d'aller voir le
dernier avenger engament avant d'aller
voir ce film car il contient des
spoilers important du dernier avengers
peter parker alias spider man souhaite
partir en vacances en europe rejoindre
ses amis et tenter de conquérir le coeur
de la gêne mjp la terre est à nouveau en
danger à ce moment là et c'est le chef
du chili qui sera rappelée à notre super
héros spider man
allez viens d'angély sympathique
arctique il se fait donc aidé par un
nouveau super-héros marvel pour liste
bec incarné par jack belink rôle afin de
sauver le monde et donc la planète terre
une mission l'on retrouve donc
énormément d'action de grands effets
spéciaux et toujours une note d'humour
dans les dialogues ce qui fait qu ceci
sera génial il vous plaira
allez donc le voir dès mercredi 3
juillet est-ce que tu va assumer
[Musique]